i've also never had cottage cheese i've
actually never even stayed in a cottage
wow yeah you have so much to you have so
much i've never stayed in a cottage and
i've never had cottage cheese that's a
true fact and i've certainly never had
cottage pie yeah i never had cottage pie
cottage cheese have had and not too bad
i love cottages though i love a cottage
really oh my god what's the last time
from fairy tales like hansel and gretel
and [ __ ] no i'd love to stay in one but
when is when does the opportunity arise
so you can stay in the cottage you can
make it happen you control your own
destiny if you want to stay in the
cottage tomorrow you can make it happen
you just don't walk around thinking
about how you're going to stay in a
cottage it's not out of reach
i love a cottage like a keebler elf
lives in there with me yeah there's a
lantern hanging off like a tree but
that's lit with gas or like a fire in it
that's a banter
like a gingerbread house here's i want
to live underneath the christmas tree
in a christmas
village like a fake christmas village
yeah in real life i want to
i want to die and come back to life as a
piece of a nativity set that would be
that's what i want to do